y dejar todo atrás para salvar la vida
esta es la realidad de más de 2 millones
de personas que han abandonado ucrania
en medio de la invasión rusa
antes de la guerra mi entonces novio y
yo nos estábamos preparando para la boda
que estaba programada para el 27 de
febrero pero sucedió que acordamos y
logramos casarnos el 24 el primer día de
la guerra ese mismo día me fui porque
kiev eran muy inseguridades lydia una
mujer embarazada fue acogida en el sur
de francia junto a otro grupo de
ucranianos
en primer lugar espero esto termine
pronto en segundo lugar en mi opinión
personal el presidente de la federación
de rusia realmente está perdiendo la
cabeza su hijo es parte del millón de
infantes que según la ong save the
children salieron del país huyendo a las
bombas la organización puntualizó que
muchos son menores de 14 años enviados
solos ante la imposibilidad de sus
parientes de salir del país
natalia hizo el viaje inverso la
ucraniana radicada en el reino unido fue
a rescatar a su hija ya su hermana pero
no pudo entrar al regreso con sus
parientes porque ellas no tenían
permisos su hija no pudo terminar la
escuela
antes de que empezara la guerra ya había
rumores de que podía haber un
enfrentamiento llamé a mi hija y le dije
hija ven con nosotros me dijo mamá me
faltan 30 días de estudios como puedo
dejar todo y marcharme al día siguiente
comenzó la guerra al
sueño
la portavoz del comité internacional de
la cruz roja enfatizó que la situación
en ucrania era apocalíptica mientras que
la oficina de derechos humanos de las
naciones unidas ha verificado hasta el
momento mil 335 víctimas incluidos
474 muertos y 861 heridos desde el
inicio del conflicto el pasado 24 de
febrero